- I don't, I don't tell myself I made it.
I don't tell myself I'm successful.
I tell myself I'm hungry
and I want to keep goin'.
So music became like
my passion, my vehicle
for you know I mean what I
was you know driven to do.
I meet fans that like have
been to like 25 shows.
And that's crazy but it's
like you could lose that trust
in an instant if you
ever broke your brand.
- He's an American rapper
and record producer.
His first major label
album These Things Happen
hit number three on
the U.S. Billboard 200.
His single, Me, Myself
and I hit number seven
on the U.S. Billboard 100.
He's G-Eazy, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the best.
And as always guys as
you're watching the videos
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Also, as you are writing something down
it's much more likely to
stick in your head, too.
Enjoy.
(lively music)
- Go hard, and then when
you think you're goin' hard,
go harder.
Like that's really it, just
hustle, you know what I mean?
There's nothin' in life that
you can't, you can't put enough
work in every single day
and not get better at.
You know what I mean?
Like if you want to be good at something,
you know what I mean, like
you can't just not like
do it every day and not get better.
It's the same beep with
music the same beep
when you learn how to play
an instrument or something.
If you spend your time
practicing your craft
like you know that's really
it, it just you know.
Cuz nowadays it's like with
the internet everything is
so accessible and you know
everybody in the world
is a rapper, you know what I mean?
Everybody's puttin' music out.
So it's like how do you stand out?
Quality's always going to matter,
but also bein' different.
You can't try to be different,
you know what I mean?
But you just got to be yourself.
- [Interviewer] What do you
credit for your success?
- Man you got to have a great team.
It's all about havin' the
right people around you.
♫ Surprise, surprise,
another night of turn up
♫ Woo hoo, it's just me, myself and I.
Both who are solid workers but also
just positive influences to
you, you know what I mean?
People that inspire you,
people who bring good energy every day.
That and just
you know hard work and dedication.
♫ And as far as I can see
♫ I just need privacy
♫ Plus a whole lot of
tree, beep all this modesty
♫ I just need space to do me
♫ Get a world away that they're tryna see
Nah, you got to have that ability
to kind of self-criticism,
you know what I mean?
And, learning and being willing to
you know to take a step
back and you know learn more
and not just feel like.
I mean a lot of times you
know it's so many artists
I just feel like now I'm
the hottest, why am I not,
you know I mean, why am I
not doing arenas right now?
Why, why am I not you know what I mean,
how did my mixtape get slept on?
And how did I, you know what I mean,
whatever but you really just got to
it's all about just payin' dues,
and just takin' that time
and just puttin' the work in.
- What are the things that
you think can distract someone
especially in the music career?
- Regular people beep, you know ever since
I finished college I'm like I been
just you know livin' off music.
And you got all this free
time, but it's on you
to like be like alright I really got to
be in the studio today.
Not just go kick it with homies,
not just like be everywhere,
not just like you know
doing all this beep.
But just like you know just, just focus.
Cuz at the end of the day
like when that work gets done
you know you can see the results.
Like it takes you places.
So for me, it's really like I
want to zero in and just focus.
And for me that was
gettin' rid of everything.
I mean success I don't think
it's something you can,
I don't think you can
you know describe success
is you know it's x.
Cuz it means different
things to different people
and there's different levels of success.
I'd say we're starting
to enjoy success now.
I bought my mom a brand
new car for her birthday.
That was definitely a
dream come true for me.
That was a level of success,
but then you look at Jay Z
you know what I'm sayin'
he'll tell you a billion is
a success when he makes
it to a B or whatever,
you know what I'm sayin'
like he's way, way, way
up there in the stratosphere.
So this just like I don't, I
don't tell myself I made it.
I don't tell myself I'm successful.
I tell myself I'm hungry
and I want to keep goin'.
I mean I grew up within
hip-hop culture, you know,
that's what I was immersed
in like as a youth.
Like that's what I was surrounded by
so naturally that's you know
what I gravitated towards
you know what I mean?
If I grew up somewhere else
maybe I would've wanted
to play guitar, like you know
sing folk songs or somethin'.
But that was just naturally
what I gravitated to
because that what I was surrounded by.
That was
my world.
I don't know, I was into music.
You know some kids were into basketball.
I wasn't very good, so
you know music was like.
I wasn't just like a kid who is you know
I don't know play video games,
or just sat on a computer
all day doing nothing.
Just I mean I was like a driven
kid, you know what I mean?
So music became like my
like passion, my vehicle
for you know what I mean what
I was you know driven to do.
And naturally it was
what I was surrounded by.
I think a lot of people kind
get it messed up like they feel
if I could only get my music
into the right person's hands
or something like that then my
life would change instantly.
And I just, I don't think
we live in that day and age
any more, you know what I mean?
It's not about waiting to be discovered
you got to discover yourself
and build your own following
and make it happen.
I meet fans that like have
been to like 25 shows.
And that's crazy but it's
like you could lose that trust
in an instant if you
ever broke your brand.
- If you ever your broke your identity
and what you stand for.
And that's why it's like
it doesn't matter how tired
I am from you know that
day's schedule or the shows
the night before, like 10 shows
in a row without a off day
or whatever, like if
I'm traveling to a city,
if I have an event, if
I'm talkin' to people,
whatever like, they don't
care about what happened
last night in Orlando, they
came here you know what I mean
for the show in the Wolnas tonight.
And you have to give it
your all and always be you
and never slack because
it's like they don't care
what you goin' late.
So you got to like always like you know.
And the same thing it's like
with an album, or a song,
or even like a feature verse
or something like that.
It's like the second you break
that you know what I mean
and then slack is like
when you let people down
and you start to lose
that brand loyalty of like
you know if you, if you
were like a Coca Cola person
and some like, you know what I mean,
like you went into a store
and you bought a Coke
and it started tastin' funny
and it just dropped off,
you know what I mean?
You wouldn't be a Coke person any more
you start messin' with
Pepsi, you know what I mean?
(audience laughing)
So it's like, you know I'm
going to jump over to this side.
It's the same thing it's like.
- And not for no reason,
it's because you'd
stopped trusting that Coke was going to be
what you rely on it for.
It's just always havin'
a strong sense of self.
And havin' that confidence, you know.
And whatever environment you're in,
you know whether good or bad,
it's just you know knowin' who you are
never reaching to try to
you know impress anybody
or be somethin' you're not,
and just feel comfortable
in your own skin, and
that's not always easy.
But it's all a process
of just finding yourself
through this journey of life.
I think the most beautiful
part about life is
finding what you love to
do and finding your place
in it, and finding a way
to make that a reality.
Whether you love to
paint, or to make music,
or to play sports, or you
know, write, whatever it is
that you love to do in
life, or whatever it is that
you love to live, or the
people you like to be around
and finding ways to make that a reality.
Like I fell in love with
hip-hop when I was real little
and I started writing
raps and making beats.
And I was like, this is what
I love to spend my time doing
I want to find a way
to make that a reality
and get to travel the
world, and get to, you know,
live the way I want to,
and share that with people.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Razvehn asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next, leave it down
in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did G-Eazy say
that had the biggest impact on you?
What lesson are you going to
take the most from this video
and immediately apply somehow
to your life or business?
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Harshith.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and making
those awesome tribute pictures
and sharing them with me.
I really, really, really
appreciate your support.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever Your One Word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- I just think music is changing in terms
of the gatekeepers and the power that be,
the powers that be.
And I feel like it's in
a more democratic time
it's like the power is
in the musicians' hands
and in the fans' hands.
I mean they choose you know what,
what matters,
what's relevant, what
sells, what you know.
It's not so much like the old
powers, the old gatekeepers
who could just shove
something down your throat.
It's like you know
you see less and less superstars
and more, and more organically
grown you know artists
like myself who are just you
know just doin' somethin'
a little different, you know
what I mean, bending genres
and don't necessarily fit
within this like format
or walls of you know whatever,
just kind of doin' their own thing.
And finding an audience
and growing it organically
and just makin' it happen.